everyone was like a little surprised on
like how much I didn't give a if
Tick Tock disappeared off the face of
the Earth if Tick Tock gets banned in
America it's actually a good thing for
us because everyone's going to be
confused where all the attention goes
and we're going to be spending our time
on Clapper or on Instagram or on Snap
Spotlight like I'll give you a bigger
one forget about Tick Tock it's all nine
social networks disappeared tomorrow I
would be thrilled because the attention
has to go somewhere I'm not emotional
about the distribution product I'm
emotional about common sense and
attention social media just happens to
be the place where the attention is now
if this was a 1968 conversation I would
be screaming at the top of my lungs
about how important television
commercials are anytime there's a shift
of attention we have grown